من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه مراسلنا
اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل اهلا بك ما طبيعه
العمليات الاسعافيه والاغاثه لديك في مجمع
الشفاء
الطبي نعم يستمر القصف الاسرائيلي في
الساعات الاخيره وفي الدقائق الاخيره قصفت
قوات الاحتلال منزلا في حي الرمال حتى هذه
اللحظه تتوافد الاصابات من تلك المنطقه
بالاضافه الى ذلك قصف طائرات الاستطلاع
والمدفعيه الاسرائيليه بشكل متكرر في
منطقه مخيم الشاطئ بشكل كثيف وهناك عدد من
الاصابات في مختلف المناطق ومع ذلك يستمر
القصف الاسرائيلي في منطقه حي حي التفاح
والدرج مع العمليات الاسرائيليه ونشاط
الميداني لقوات الاحتلال في تلك المنطقه
قوات الاحتلال عملت على التقدم من محورين
في الى منطقه التفاح والدرج من محور منطقه
حي الشجاعيه ومن محور منطقه حي الشيخ
رضوان هاتين المنطقتين المطل التين على
منطقه حي التفاح والدرج بالاضافه الى ذلك
القصف العنيف والاحزمه الناريه التي التي
تعرضت لها هذه المنطقه مساء امس حتى صباح
اليوم ويستمر نشاط قوات الاحتلال في تلك
المنطقه بالاضافه الى ذلك تقدم قوات
الاحتلال الى مخيم جباليا بشكل ملحوظ هذه
العمليات الميدانيه المتكرره والمتواصل
لقوات الاحتلال في الميدان تتعرض قوات
الاحتلال لمواجهات ضاريه ومقاومه عنيفه في
مختلف المحاور ومن جميع الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وعلى راس هذه الفصائل كتائب
القسامه التي تضرب قوات الاحتلال بمختلف
الاسلحه سواء العبوات او قذائف الياسين
والمئه وخمسه وقذائف
الار بي جي بالاضافه الى ذلك اعل كتاب
القسام يوم امس انها فجرت خمس دبابات
بصاروخين اف 16 لم ينفجرا من مخلفات قوات
الاحتلال وادى ذلك الى تدمير الدبابات
بشكل كامل واحداث ضرر كبير في قوات
الاحتلال وهذا ملحوظ في عدد قتل الاحتلال
مع اجداد المواجهات الضاريه في مختلف
المحاور لكن على المستوى الانساني هناك
استغاثات كبيره من وزاره الصحه في مجمع
الشفاء الطب ال طبي وضروره النداء على
الطواقم الطبيه بالتوجه الى مجمع الشفاء
الطبي ومختلف النقاط الطبيه التي انشاتها
وزاره الصحه لمساعده الطواقم الطبيه
العامله في هذه النقاط علما ان مستشفى
الشفاء لا يتوفر به الا خمس اطباء ويعمل
هؤلاء الاطباء على خدمه عدد كبير من
المرضى بالاضافه الى ذلك المختبر الذي
استطاعت الطواقم الطبيه تشغيله بالحد
الادنى وبحاجه الى وحدات دم مختلفه سواء
من بالتحديد فصيلتي اي سالب وا واو سالب
هاتين الفصيلتين هما الندي
وهم بحاجه كبيره لانقاذ حياه المرضى خاصه
مرضى التلاسيميا الذين يتعرضون لخطر كبير
من فقدان حياتهم في ظل الحصار الاسرائيلي
المستمر على الطواقم الطبيه وعلى
مختلف المستشفيات والوزارات الصحيه
بالاضافه الى ذلك ان المختبرات هي بحاجه
الى قدرات طبيه ومهندسين وفنيين فمن يمتلك
القدره وجهت وزاره الصحه نداء الى مختلف
الفنيين بالتوجه ايضا الى المستشفيات
وبالتحديد مستشفى الشفاء للمساعده في
مسانده التوق الطبيه والعمل على انقاذ
حياه المرضى
الذين الذين حياتهم مهدده بالخطر في ظل
نقص الكوادر الطبيه والمعدات الطبيه
اللازمه شكرا لك اسماعيل الغول مراسلنا من
مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه